this indian restaurant in bradford has
cooked up a way of helping out with the
push to get everyone boosted so along
with your papadoms and naans you can
also ask for a side order of covid19
vaccine whether your staff or a diner
yeah i think it's a great idea because
you can hang out with your friends have
something to eat and get a job and go on
the restaurant has previously partnered
with the nhs to vaccinate their staff
and to host q a sessions for anyone with
concerns about the vaccinations
a lot of our team members wanted to
do the waxing anyway but they just don't
have the time so we thought we'd create
a platform for customers and team
members where they can come and if
somebody wants to take the job
and it's just because of convenience
they can take it and same with the team
members if they want to take it whilst
at work
they can do so
in the seven days up to monday there
were over 2 000 positive test results in
bradford an increase of 33 percent on
the week before but vaccination levels
are comparatively low in the area around
the restaurant less than 50 percent of
over 12s have had their first dose
compared to almost 90 percent nationally
and only 39
have had a second dose across the rest
of the uk that total is over 80 percent
we appreciate there are that some people
are cautious
and it is our job and we are spending a
lot of time to encourage as many people
as we can
to come forward and have the
vaccinations so we've created a lot of
accesses such as this
walk-in access clinics throughout the
district to encourage people to come
forward and where they feel comfortable
to have that vaccine
the restaurant is one of dozens of
pop-up and walk-in clinics around the
country which the nhs hopes will make it
easier for people to get vaccinated even
those who feel they already have a lot
on their plate over christmas
fraser moored sky news bradford